il y avait trois millions et demi de
juifs en pologne avant la guerre une
communauté qui était là depuis le 11e
siècle 80% ont péri pendant ce qu'on
appelle le low cost ou la shoah
l'élimination systématique des juifs la
pologne était avant la shoah la patrie
juive
l'immense majorité des juifs ashkénazes
du monde ont des racines polonaises
c'est ici que ça se passe et constantine
gay berthe est un célèbre journaliste de
varsovie et militants juifs polonais on
vient d'inaugurer à varsovie un musée de
l'histoire juive sur le site même du
ghetto où les nazis avaient enfermé la
population juive à cracovie
l'ancien quartier juif a été rénové
est-ce qu'on assiste à une renaissance
juive en pologne
il n'y a pas une renaissance du judaïsme
polonais on est trop nombreux pour cela
à mais il y a développement d'intérêt
approfondie pour l'histoire juive de la
pologne
depuis 1988 il ya même chaque année un
festival de musique et de culture juive
dans ce quartier de kazimierz à cracovie
c'était le quartier juif où habitait
60000 personnes avant la guerre so what
jim crow nous avons fait revivre la
culture juive à casimir nous avons fait
revivre une culture juive à cracovie
nous avons même fait plus que cela
j'insiste sur ce point nous avons
redonné aux juifs leur place à cracovie
casimir est maintenant un quartier à la
mode
envahie par les touristes c'est devenu
une étape obligée avant la visite à
auschwitz à 60 kilomètres de là on tente
d'y recréer l'atmosphère d'avant guerre
il ya de nombreux restaurants juifs non
casher dirigé par des non juifs
il ya des ruelles c'est le décor du
cinéma avec de fausses devant tueur de
boutiques il y un centre communautaire
juif qui date de 2008
cette synagogue ont survécu mais la
plupart ne sont plus des lieux de prière
dans l'une d'elles il y à chaque semaine
un concert de musique juive polonaise
mais aucun des musiciens nés juifs
l'endroit ouvre toutes grandes ses
portes aux touristes mais bien peu de
juifs sont revenus y vivre moins de 200
alors qu'avant la guerre ils étaient des
dizaines de milliers
je suis quand même conscients que nous
vivons sur un immense cimetière trois
millions et demi de juifs polonais ont
été exécutés
ils ont été tués par nos voisins très
instruits de l'ouest les allemands qui
veut vivre sur un cimetière
dans la synagogue isaac une des sept que
compte le quartier de kazimierz c'est la
prière du matin
l'endroit est pratiquement vide et ne
sont que 5 à prier dans une petite pièce
pourtant cracovie était jadis un haut
lieu des écrits religieux la plupart des
lois qu'observent les juifs ashkénazes
ont été écrites dans cette ville les
quelques juifs qui vivent à cracovie
comme le rabbin eliezer gourari n'ont
pas l'impression d'être de simples
figurants dans un paysage envahie par
les touristes
il témoigne de ce passé juif et
affirment que leur culture a malgré tout
survécu bigpark des statistiques photos
historiques partir des stations de
l'effort joey starr co 2 par km de plage
en tout 21 franchement si on si je
pouvais avoir le soir d'abord une
culture unique produite par les juifs
plutôt que par des noms bon alors vous
dire je suis raciste j'aurais préféré
une culture produit par diffic ceci dit
j'ai pas ce choix
on est trop peu pour être culture non
créatifs donc ou bien on aura une
culture juive produite largement par des
non juifs ou bien on en aura pas ceci
dit j'accepte pleinement et profond
avait traduit sens le fait qu'ils que le
problème s'est réglé
de cette façon et non pas de l'autre
façon possible c'est-à-dire non
existence de plus tu rejoues d'oublier
complètement